es ist tag zwei nach der europawahl und
in berlin wien und brüssel ist echt was
los
die große koalition hat an zustimmung
verloren und die beiden parteichefin in
alesund kramp karrenbauer sorgen auf
ganz unterschiedliche weise für
ziemliche aufregung in wien wurde die
ganze regierung abgewählt und auch heute
abend beim ersten eu-gipfel nach der
wahl da geht es durch das schlechte
abschneiden der volksparteien nicht
einfach weiter so bei der bestimmung des
personals nach dem wahl-debakel cdu und
spd in town
das ist unser thema heute
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend herzlich willkommen
aus berlin ich freue mich auf die
diskussion mit diesen gästen professor
kathrin stainer hämmerle ist bei uns sie
ist professorin für
politikwissenschaften an der
fachhochschule kärnten in villach in
österreich und erklärt uns natürlich mal
die lage in wien
ich begrüße professor andreas rödder
geschichte professor für neueste
geschichte an der johannes gutenberg
universität in mainz bekennender
konservativer und sein neuestes buch wer
hat angst vor deutschland beschäftigt
sich mit der rolle unseres landes für
europa die jung ist bei uns freier
chefredakteur der interviewsendung jung
und naiv politik für das interessierte
und verantwortlich für den podcast
aufwachen herzlich willkommen ralf
schule
seit 2011 ist er leiter der
parlamentsredaktion von bild er
berichtet vor allem über die cdu/csu und
über die kanzlerin begleitet sie oft auf
reisen und in seinem buch lasst uns
populisten sein plädiert er für eine
neue streitkultur
herr jung es war die europawahl und
trotzdem gucken jetzt alle vor allen
dingen auf die große koalition ich habe
es schon gesagt beide parteichefin
sorgen für aufregung andrea nahles will
die vertrauensfrage nächste woche in der
fraktionssitzung stellen annegret kramp
karrenbauer da gibt es viel aufregung
weil sie sich über meinungsfreiheit im
netz geäußert hat und gefragt hat ob es
regeln geben müsse für
meinungsäußerungen im internet ein junge
mit blonden mit blauen haaren hat das
alles ausgelöst
wieso mit seinem video hat er ist das
wirklich liegt es an ihm hat er so viel
macht ich glaube nicht ich glaube das
wird also müssen überschätzt
ich glaube das haben sich die meisten
wähler und die darin schon vor ein paar
tage vorher überlegt ob sie der union
oder der spd ihre stimme geben
ich glaube risiko hat nicht geholfen
aber das ist glaube ich auch nicht
schlecht ich bin froh dass die jugend
sich da ein gehör verschafft hat und
dass die beiden vorsitzenden jetzt unter
druck geraten ich glaube das ist völlig
normal bei einer so krasse niederlage
aber wieso hat in seinem video auch
sachen von ihrem von jungen ihre
plattformen ja auch sehr viel benutzt
haben sie damit gerechnet dass das so
viel aufregung gibt nein ich meine ich
habe im vorfeld hatte ich ja mit ihm in
kontakt weil er sich im park wellen
besorgt hat
ich hatte natürlich gehofft dass das
irgendwie ein bisschen impact hat weil
er ja natürlich ein größerer youtuber
ist als als ich zum beispiel erreicht
ganz andere zielgruppen
aber als ich das zum ersten mal gesehen
hat habe an dem samstag hätte ich nie
und habe damit gerechnet ich kann's geil
es war sensationell aber dass das quasi
in andere blasen überschwappt ja in den
politischen journalismus ins
regierungsviertel an die kaffee an den
kaffeetisch bei oma erna oder soweit
hätte ich nicht mitgerechnet
herr schuler erfinden sie das hätten sie
mit so etwas gerechnet und was sagt das
eigentlich ja über die art der
kommunikation dass dieses video
sozusagen eine ganze parteizentrale so
in aufruhr bringen kann also man muss es
ganz klar sagen rieso oder rät zu einer
neuen richtung riesa hat die union
einfach kalt erwischt das ist einfach so
es gab sehr früh nachdem es im netz
auftauchte anfragen was macht ihr
reagiert darauf und es kam zunächst erst
mal nichts und die union ist komplett in
gestalt der führungs zentrale erstarrt
im nachdenken darüber prominent
ignorieren oder aber hart darauf
reagieren wenn ja wie reagieren und
dieser nachdenkprozess der im
internetzeitalter einfach nicht drei
tage dauern darf hat dann bis mittwoch
gedauert mittwoch früher hatte man sich
entschlossen ein geheimes video mit
herrn am tor zu produzieren hat das dann
auch schon über verschiedene kanäle in
aussicht gestellt auch schon fotos davon
herumgeschickt und dann doch einen
rückzieher gemacht eine größere
peinlichkeit ist nicht zu denken also
die union hat sich selbst reingeritten
ansonsten hätte das video möglicherweise
gar nicht so viel aufruhr verursacht
glauben sie denn dass das entscheidend
war für diese wähle ich glaube schon
dass es eine große popularität unter
jungen wählern hat nur die szene die man
mit yuan erreicht hat ist traditionell
nicht die stärkste bei der union also
ich glaube nicht dass da ein riesen
wechselwähler run losgegangen ist dass
die dann also haben gut also werden der
das schon sagt dann gehen wir zu den
grünen
so einfach funktioniert es dann doch
nicht er war da was sagt das über den
zustand der cdu die jetzt so abgestraft
wurde bei derweil die stark verloren hat
die spd hat auch stark verloren bei
dieser europawahl
jetzt gibt es die neue aufregung darüber
dass krieg kramp karrenbauer sagt wir
brauchen vielleicht andere
regeln wenn wir im meinungsäußerungen im
netz haben und darüber gibt es auch
wieder ganz viel kritik also inflation
zustand ist nicht die union grad ich
glaube wir sollten in dieser diskussion
ein paar dinge auseinanderhalten
tatsächlich hat dieses video von rhi so
einen prozess verstärkte schon länger im
gang war und es ist ein prozess der wenn
er so weiter geht in einer implosion der
beiden großen volksparteien enden kann
wir erleben ja von wahl zu wahl eine
entwicklung dass die parteien ergebnisse
gut fänden die noch bei der letzten wahl
katastrophen ergebnisse waren und der
beschleunigte verfall der spd hat ja den
blick auf den parallelen prozess in der
cdu oftmals nur verstellt wir sind
mittlerweile davon arbeit an dem punkt
angelangt wo die beiden parteien der
großen koalition mehr und mehr davon
entfernt sind überhaupt noch eine
mehrheit mit einander zu haben
das ist ja eine diskussion ich würde
dann davon unterscheiden dass herr
schuler gerade sagte die reaktion der
cdu führung auf das video aber noch
einmal eine andere frage ist die frage
die annegret kramp karrenbauer gestern
aufgeworfen hat und das wird jetzt in
der ganzen großen aufregung alles in
eines gerührt aber tatsächlich annegret
kramp karrenbauer ja eine ganz zentrale
und wichtige frage aufgeworfen nämlich
die inwiefern das internet die digitale
kommunikation der internetwelt eine
kommunikation in einem rechtsfreien raum
ist oder inwiefern es regeln geben
sollte die auch die digitale
kommunikation betreffen so wie es auf
analoge ebene in den printmedien auch
der fall ist und das ist tatsächlich
eine ganz zentrale diskussion die
einfach damit zu tun hat dass wir
historisch immer wieder beobachten das
neue kräfte freigesetzt werden und die
dann nach regeln verlangen
das gilt für den kapitalismus im 19
jahrhundert gegen sowie die digitale
hört der meinung es kommt aber etwas
komisch an weil man das gefühl sie ist
angegriffen worden und jetzt sagt sie
das darf doch so nicht sein deswegen
geht da eines ins andere
ich vermischt sich miteinander aber wir
haben es tatsächlich mit
unterschiedlichen fragen zu tun die man
auch unterschiedlich thematisieren muss
herr jung was würden sie denn sagen
brauchen wir andere regeln
die regel gibt es ja schon ersten
sondern das grundgesetz das ist alles
festgelegt die meinung darf nicht
reguliert werden ist ein grundrecht
brauchen wir nicht drüber reden und es
gibt auch regeln für youtube also ich
muss mich an youtube regeln halten wenn
ich videos hochladen ich dachte da keine
leonards die scheiße hochladen oder es
videos oder so weiter und so weiter
darum nein also das reicht völlig würden
sie sagen und was halten sie denn von
der äußerung von frau kramp karrenbauer
dass sie gesagt hat sie hat ja gesagt
ich zitiere sie mal was wäre eigentlich
in diesem land los von einer reihe von
70 zeitungsredaktionen zwei tage vor der
wahl erklärt hätte wir machen einen
gemeinsamen aufruf welt bitte nicht cdu
und spd das hätte zu heftigen debatten
geführt heute hat sie dann etwas
veröffentlicht und hat dann gesagt
meinungsfreiheit und meinungsvielfalt
werden wir alle in der cdu immer
verteidigen aber es ist eine frage des
umgangs miteinander muss es trotzdem
noch mal eine veränderung geben des
umgangs vielleicht also ich finds ja ich
fände es schade wenn die älteren die
politik machen sich vielleicht mit den
jüngeren auseinandersetzen man muss man
muss sich ja nicht mehr gleich treffen
und öffentlich irgendwo irgendwas
zelebrieren
aber was wäre denn eine gute reaktion
gewesen was hätten sie gut gefunden von
der cdu im umgang mit diesem video
ihr habt recht man einfach sagen müssen
ihr habt recht weil das allermeiste ja
sogar zu beschuldigen die in der form in
der form kann man darüber streiten um
konservative regen sich darüber auf aber
wieso hat er mit allen dem was er gesagt
hat recht und daher die cdu aber nicht
sagen müssen
ok aber ich hatte ja so kann doch
demokratische kommunikation nicht
stattfinden sie können doch nicht 55
minuten lang eine kanonade ablassen und
dann sagen ich verlange jetzt dass man
sagt du hast in allen punkten recht das
ist doch genau das problem dass unsere
demokratie heute kennzeichnet dass wir
absolut heitz ansprüche auf der linken
und auf der rechten seite haben dass wir
die moralisierung der eigenen position
erleben die die position des landes
gar nicht mehr als legitim respektiert
und wenn das stattfindet ist eine
demokratie im kern gefährdet und
insofern erleben wir hier tatsächlich
etwas was die demokratie und die
debattenkultur in deutschland bestätigt
rede so kann man dich akuten krise und
die youtuber die sich zusammengetan und
gefährden die demokratie ja mit dieser
form der kommunikation die verlangt dass
sich 55 minuten ein statement ab lasse
und das einzige was ich dann dazu
erwartet
und das einzige was ich als legitim
gelten lasse ist dass derjenige den ich
kritisiere dann sagt ja du hast recht so
kann demokratie so kann demokratische
meinungsbildung nicht stattfinden ich
glaube dass unsere demokratie wäre
beschädigt wenn das nicht möglich wäre
also ich bin froh dass es in unserem
land möglich ist es ist in allen anderen
westlichen ländern auch möglich dass es
tanja möglich da ist es standard dass
prominente in amerika sich zusammentun
und online gegen donald trump aufrufen
gegen seine wahl da wird das von
deutschen medien gefeiert und das ist
doch etwas ganz anderes ist das ist
nichts passiert ich habe auch an diesem
youtube also in jedem youtuber aufrufen
mitgemacht aber nicht basierend auf
jesus video sondern auf basierend auf
meinen auf meine arbeit in den letzten
fünf jahren bewährung geben gerade gar
nicht von den 70 youtube angesprochen
auch darüber kann man reden sondern ich
hab kommentiert dass sie sagten die
einzig wirklich legitime reaktionen der
cdu wäre gewesen zu kapitulieren und zu
sagen ja du hast recht das ist eine
andere frage
sie hat mich nach der besten reaktion
gefragt aus sicht von jungen hätte ich
gesagt die cdu hatte gesagt naja culpa
eines klar wir können wir weiter dass
das ende des diskurses weil das was in
dem video gezeigt wurde von rio waren
halt alte debatten die schon tausendfach
auch im bundestag geführt worden sind
über die schere zwischen arm und reich
über den klima politik das ist alles
tausendmal diskutiert worden auch
konzentriert
die ewigkeit in deutschland ist immer
noch riesig der klimaschutz kommt gar
nicht strom an
wir wählen lassen menschen über mit
drohnen töten ist rammstein das sind
doch alles legitime sachen wie alles ja
aber die kontrolle position kam
überhaupt nicht zu worte bei der seine
eigene position karikari es ist einfach
das problem dass dort der
berichterstatter und der politische
aktivist in einer person auftreten das
würde man zeitungen nie durchgehen
lassen als bild -zeitung weiß ich wovon
man redet dass wir einfach nicht im tor
steht und kann
macht ja kampagnen ist ja nicht so dass
die gegen drogen wir müssen uns nun
entscheiden welche der bild -zeitung
kampagnen vor
dann müssten sie auch dort vorwerfen
oder samba ok kampagnen sind immer gut
dann ist beides in ordnung das müssten
wir schon auseinanderhalten das andere
ist die politisch gesehen war die
situation wenn eine wahl verloren hast
und dann sagst du hier aber das geht
nicht wenn man die regel das ist eine
unglückliche konstellation ich hab ja
selbst die frage gestellt in der
pressekonferenz da ist irgendwie dann
ist er auf getroffen worden
grundsätzlich finde ich dass sich einen
medien etabliert was gar nicht unbedingt
immer qualifiziert sein muss das finde
ich schon in ordnung also dass in 1
sätzen eines berichterstatters eines
argument tigers mit einem politischen
akteur ist eine unglückliche
zusammenkunft das wollen wir in
zeitungen auch nicht haben
trotz seiner heimat wäre schon mal eben
nach österreicher wollen sind damit in
die diskussion nehmen wie ist es da also
wenn diese da gibt es ja auch eine sehr
aufgeheizte debatte es gab eine
krisenstimmung wie sie so noch nie gab
in ihrem land nach diesem video was
publiziert worden ist also wie geht man
da dann damit um wie im ja wenn im netz
kritik geäußert wird und wer gewinnt da
die schlachten bei facebook und in
zucker also wir kämpfen ja mit den
folgen eines ganz anderen videos sehr
ich glaube ich auch weitaus dramatischer
sind als wir hier in deutschland
und da geht es natürlich sehr stark
darum ist dieses video widerrechtlich
aufgenommen
ob es es gibt schon die ersten klagen
interessant ist auch dass es über
deutsche medien gespielt wurde und nicht
über österreichische das sagt auch schon
viel über sage ich nenne jetzt das enge
verhältnis zwischen politik und medien
vielleicht in österreich aber das harz
schlussendlich auch glaube ich der
freiheitlichen partei geholfen jetzt bei
der letzten wahl weil sie sagen konnte
das war ein angriff aus deutschland dass
diese kampagne mit jetzt erst recht und
wir lassen uns nicht in die innenpolitik
hineinreden von deutschen medien und der
eu hält 17,5 jahre haben sie hat zwar
zwei prozentpunkte verloren aber in
absoluten stimmen hunderttausend stimmen
mehr gemacht es hat natürlich auch mit
der gestiegenen wahlbeteiligung zu tun
gut es lässt sich jetzt nicht trennen
wie wäre das ergebnis gewesen ohne
dieses video
aber weil sie hier nicht haben in
österreich sind natürlich so mächtige
youtube und blogger die jugendliche so
beeinflussen dass mir scheint also ich
glaube auch wieso ich kein journalist
und kann ihnen keine journalistischen
maßstäbe anlegen
er ist natürlich aktiv ist und was ich
aber schon glaube was jetzt die
etablierten politikerinnen und politiker
ein wenig ärgert ist dass eine person
eine einzelne person im grunde dieselbe
fast dieselbe medienmacht hat wie er sie
ja die politiker immer hatten die können
ja immer an ein millionenpublikum
kommunizieren was junge menschen vorher
nicht kannten ja und das ist jetzt
natürlich unangenehm und ärgerlich das
mag schon sein aber an sie jetzt die
gleichen maßstäbe zu legen wie man es
eigentlich nur öffentlich-rechtliche
medien tut ja nicht einmal an private
medien das halte ich schon für überzogen
aber wie gesagt wir führen diese debatte
nicht in dem ausmaß wir haben einige
sehr dominierende blogger im internet
wir wissen was aber wirkliche macht
erreichen sie eigentlich nur wenn es die
traditionellen medien aufnehmen
ich habe aber es sollte auch ganz stark
im netz die die fpö hat natürlich sich
dadurch dass wir ja sehr starkes
öffentlich-rechtliches medium haben und
sie sich immer schlecht behandelt
gefühlt haben zum teil auch zum recht
haben sie sich seit jahren eine eigene
medienmacht aufgebaut also heinz
christian strache 800.000 facebook-fans
das ist schon eine macht das problem
zeigt sich jetzt aber auch jetzt ist er
nicht mehr parteichef und niemand kann
so schnell seine fans übernehmen also
sich dann auch gleichzeitig seine
schwäche frau steiner himmel spricht er
etwas ganz grundlegendes an wir erleben
ja eine ganz fundamentale veränderung
der struktur der öffentlichkeit und der
öffentlichen kommunikation
wir haben seit der aufklärung im grunde
ein system etabliert wo medien die
ermittler sind das sagt ja schon der
begriff zwischen bevölkerung und den
handelnden vermitteln und journalisten
sind und das sind sie mit der
klassischen demokratie des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zunehmend geworden diese
mittler gatekeeper zwischen bevölkerung
und politisch handelnden und das feld
durch die neuen formen der direkten
kommunikation
das verändert politik ganz grundlegend
und das ändert die situation für die
politisch etablierten parteien und ist
verschafft vorteile für diejenigen die
mit dieser direkten kommunikation
politik machen können das gilt für trump
das gilt für die afg und für diese
blogger da ist ein struktur prozessen
aber handeln nicht jetzt bei dieser
europawahl vor allen dingen ein problem
oder ein problem für die für die
etablierten parteien für spd und cdu
dass die jungen nicht mehr zu diesen
parteien gehen und sich damit nicht mehr
verstanden werden der schule ist das
nicht das problem man noch ein bisschen
den blick noch mal woanders hin zu
richten dass wir sagen in der seit
diesem verein ist future bewegung dass
das was ist was spd und cdu einfach ja
verschlafen haben ich glaube dagegen
bald ein bisschen zu kurz es gab immer
die ganz grossen wellen die die jungen
auch mobilisiert haben das waren zum
beispiel die friedens proteste anfang
der 80er jahre der mit der bonner
hofgarten die älteren erinnern sich
hunderttausende die die ursprungs
bewegung der grünen hat mobilisiert die
anti-akw-bewegung hat riesig mobilisiert
gerade auch unter jungen es gab immer
diese bewegung die auch immer sehr
radikal waren und nicht durch abwägung
von argumenten atomausstieg oder sollte
unbedingt frieden seien rund damit den
waffen punkt das war so ein bisschen die
greta nur auf einem anderen
politikbereich also würde sagen es kommt
immer meinen werden und man sich weiter
darum zu können nein das wollte ich eben
gerade nicht sagen denn damals gab es
keine digitalisierung und die
digitalisierung führt dazu dass den
massen die medien in die hand gegeben
sind was früher die massenmedien waren
hat heute jeder in der hand und da sind
wir genau bei dem problem was ich auch
im buch versuche zu beschreiben in dem
moment wo wir sagen populisten das ist
so ein schmuddel sektor an dem arbeiten
wir uns nicht abnehmen lassen wir rechts
oder links liegen und versuchen einfach
weiter unseren stiefel in der mitte zu
machen drängen wir die ins netz mit
allen folgen und mit allen milieus die
sich dann mit eigenen wahrheiten
versorgung die sich verhärten und
zusammenschließen und die wir hinterher
politisch auf der allgemeinen
öffentlichen bühne nicht mehr erreichen
könnten wir drängen sich deshalb ins
netz weil er keine antworten für sie als
die genau das ist genau das problem aber
anderen jungs stelle dagegen verwahren
bei frau seiner heimat gesagt hat die
öffentlich-rechtlichen da hat man in
anderen anspruch dran
ich finde jeder der in der
öffentlichkeit agiert sollte eigentlich
ein einigermaßen hohen anspruch an sich
und anders
was er macht haben weil sonst haben wir
ja eine mehr klassen medien herr jung
warum warum erreichen cdu und spd die
jungen leute nicht mehr warum warum
sollten sie sie erreichen die jungen
leute interessieren sich nicht dafür
warum nicht warum
warum geben sie weil diese parteien und
was sie beschließen fast nichts mit dem
realen leben dieser jungen menschen zu
tun haben das einzige was jetzt aufkommt
womit sie quasi ihr leben verbinden ist
ihre zukunft und der klimaschutz darum
geht das jetzt so hoch und das wird auch
so bleiben das ist keine phase das wird
sich alles noch verschärfen ich glaube
einen radikalen bereich sind wir noch
längst nicht und mir ist aufgefallen
weil sie das gerade gesagt haben es ist
ein österreicher anders als in
deutschland da sind die politiker stark
in den sozialen medien und es gibt kaum
starke blogger und youtube und
deutschland es genau andersrum
also es gibt ganz wenige politiker die
starke reichweite stark auf facebook
sind das ist glaube ich gleich sahra
wagenknecht und ein paar fehler also an
den rändern und das finde ich schon mal
interessant und zu der frage von vorhin
mit ak und ihre aussage das ist ja
natürlich interessant gerade mit dem
hintergrund als sie ins amt gekommen ist
hat sie angekündigt dass die cdu ein
newsroom bekommen soll cdu tv war es
natürlich an eine anlehnung ist an apple
tv und in die bastille afd machen würde
das sind also das jetzt finde ich am
allerschlimmsten an dieser ganzen
entwicklung sie hat ja auch im magazin
der jungen union ihr auftaktgespräch zum
zum werkstattgespräch damals als ich
angetreten ist thematisiert und hat sie
ganz gelobt gesagt ich zitiere sie wir
waren her über die bilder wir haben die
nachrichten selbst produziert in diese
richtung wird es gehen also eigentlich
müssten wir wenn wir über regulierungen
reden regulierung bei den parteien und
was sie im netz machen dürfen die dürfe
nämlich kein parteien tv machen und
keine regierungs tv und das versuchen
parteien und ressourcen also wie ist das
in österreich ist da die sozusagen
verhalten es vorgemacht und waren damit
eben auch erfolgreich also wir haben im
grunde nicht alle politiker in
österreich sind stark vertreten auf
facebook sondern genau genommen zwei
eigentlich mit der strache eben nicht
für vizekanzler in populistischen
ansätzen die wirklich über jahre
systematisch eine gegenmacht zu den
traditionellen medien aufgebaut haben
und wie 1 1 geholt hat relativ kurz in
kurzer zeit vor der letzten
parlamentswahl war dann sebastian kurz
und eigentlich diese beiden haben es
verstanden junge zu erreichen zumindest
über die richtigen kanäle und
selbstverständlich wenn wir uns alle
verantwortungsvoll in der öffentlichkeit
verhalten jahr geschenkt dann brauchen
wir viel nicht aber das wird nicht so
sein aber es wäre also eben schon auch
in deutschland ist im grunde auch eine
rückkehr der partei presse und zwar ganz
stark und die sind nicht ausgewogen oder
bringen die richtigen argumente also in
österreich versuchen die parteien ganz
massiv eben apple tv über sehr ähnlich
ausschauen der plattformen der compo
fest sein das ist eine traditionelle
medienunternehmen und und auch eine
nachrichtensendung versuchen sie ihre
wirklichkeit so darzustellen wie sie
nicht ist oder nur halt in ihren augen
sein soll selber ja ganz so ausgewogen
agieren leider auch andere ich würde
gerne mal ein bisschen auf dieses junge
kommen und nicht nur auf die medien
schauen wenn sie sagt der kanzler kurz
ist selber erst 32 jahre alt ist das
sozusagen eine garantie dafür dass die
jungen leute auch die svp wählen also
bei der europawahl haben sie mich
gewählt auch hier haben wir gesehen
junge frauen zu den grünen junge männer
zu den freiheitlichen partei wenn man
ganz eine starke ist unterschiedliches
auch gap in geschlechter wahlverhalten
sowohl bei den jungen als auch bei den
alten also insofern ein weil er ich
glaube nach wie vor die themen nicht
richtig besetzt hat zwar die kanäle aber
auch das klima thema haben sie in
österreich vollkommen verschlafen
alle partei also insofern gerade die evb
mit landwirtschaftsministerium seit
jahrzehnten
da hat man schon auch gemerkt hier hier
sind sie sie haben sollte dann doch
lieber sein verschlafen das wichtigste
thema und wir regen uns auch dass uns
ein junger mensch daran daran erinnert
er war der ist dann am gerät kam kern
bauer noch die richtige
parteivorsitzende wenn sie jetzt in so
kurzer zeit das wichtigste thema
verschläft und dann auf diesen
ja diesen umgang mit medien im internet
so reagiert dass sie sich den zorn auch
ihrer eigenen partei so aufzieht jetzt
ist erst einmal die frage was heißt das
wichtigste thema verschläft reden wir
jetzt schon digitaler kommunikation oder
vom klimawandel ihm aber das ist ja
nicht frau kramp karrenbauers problemen
kanzlerin ist nicht frau kramp
karrenbauer frau kramp karrenbauer hat
sich aber sie ist es nicht deswegen ist
sie jetzt auch nicht dafür
verantwortlich hier werden auch
verantwortlichkeiten im moment in einer
weise freihändig durch die
öffentlichkeit geschoben die einer
abgewogenen und etwas nachdenklichen
diskussionen widersprechen
und dass sie sich ungeschickt verhalten
hatte im umgang mit diesen dingen die
den letzten tagen aufgekommen sind das
steht hier glaube ich außer debatte und
dennoch erlauben sie mir dass ich eine
bemerkung nochmal zu dieser
öffentlichkeit machen
da geht im moment auch so völlig
undifferenziert dieser begriff
meinungsfreiheit durch die lande
natürlich ist die meinungsfreiheit
vielleicht sogar das zentrale grundrecht
neben dem artikel 1 des grundgesetzes
nur es gibt nicht die öffentlichkeit und
die meinungsfreiheit und ganz oder gar
nicht mit einem an oder aus schalter 1
oder 0
auch öffentlichkeit ist ja etwas was
strukturiert und geregelt wird und wo
sich dinge unterscheiden
es macht einen unterschied ob ich eine
private äußerung treffe ob ich eine
presserechtliche äußerung treffe oder ob
ich sogar unter den
rundfunkstaatsvertrag falle das macht
für die das macht für öffentlichkeit
einen ganz erheblichen unterschied oder
ein anderes beispiel ist die akteure der
politischen bildung haben sich vor über
40 jahren auf den sogenannten
beutelsbacher konsens geeinigt nämlich
auf das prinzip des überwältigung
verbotes das ist ein geheiligt das
prinzip der politischen bildung überall
im gesamten land und ich halte das für
völlig richtig wahr heißt dass ich
meinem gegenüber nicht einfach zu
hämmern darf und überwältigen darf mit
dem was ich ihm an den kopf knallen so
dass er überhaupt keine chance mehr hat
darüber irgendwie nach ca
der grundsatz der in unseren schulen
herrscht und in der politischen bildung
herrscht und dieses video von reso ich
sage es noch einmal das ist natürlich
überwältigung rhetorik und das kann man
als solche zu machen aber man kann nicht
verlangen dass dass der standard der
diskussion aber ohne dass sich reese und
das sichere sodann der diskussion
entzieht da muss ich noch mal sein so
können sie keine öffentlichkeit machen
und öffentlichkeit wird auf der einen
seite schon durch rechte geregelt und
durch und auf der anderen seite durch
formen geregelt die wir miteinander
vereinbaren und für richtig halten wenn
man sich daran nicht hält dann kann man
dann macht man öffentlichkeit kaputt er
aber ist dass dieses video ist auch
ausdruck von einem nicht verstanden
werden und von einer kritik an einer
partei an einer politik die alben an
vielen was die jungs ist ein bio ist
sein geht es nicht mehr sagte heise das
gehört das video ist zunächst einmal
eine zusammenstellung von allem was mir
irgendwie nicht passt da sind lauter
dinge über die man sehr viel lieber über
fairplay das heißt belegt dass werden
dinge behauptet was die armutsquoten
angeht das stimmt doch hinten und vorne
nicht das ist populismus 4.0 dieses
video
okay sie wollten aus dem der jeder frei
sozusagen eine andere meinung zu äußern
doch die frage ist pluralismus ergänzen
möchte ich den ball fußball konsens mit
dem kontrovers idee aufgebot also dinge
die kontroversen muss sich so darstellen
aber das gilt ja nicht für jede einzelne
person sondern das gilt für die schule
selbstverständlich das gilt für die
medien
aber wir müssen sie einen so gesehen
also jeder kann sich hier hinstellen ein
neues video machen und dem herrn rieso
widersprechen
ich würde jetzt auch mal gerne nach
vorne schauen und die frage wie sollen
die parteien spd und cdu beide jetzt
darauf reagieren wir schauen auch
nochmal auf die spd die auch noch mal
ganz andere probleme hat jetzt die frage
sich stellt sind wir eigentlich noch
volkspartei mit 15,8 prozent dass sie
hinter den grünen landen der schule aus
ihrer erfahrung als politischer
korrespondent ihr ist die haben die spd
und die cdu der eigentlich dasselbe
probleme sie haben sie das problem weil
sie in dieser großen koalition
miteinander sind dass sie so abgestraft
werden sie haben schon ein ähnliches
problem nur die bei der union
das noch eine weile dauern bis sie da
ankommt wo die spd jetzt ist bei der spd
haben wir das große problem dass sie
kaum noch vermittelt bekommt welche
funktionen sie im parteiengefüge hat die
sozialen gesetzgebungs projekte die sie
in den letzten legislatur sehr
erfolgreich durchgebracht hat vom
mindestlohn über
entgeltgleichheitsgesetz rente mit 63
jetzt arbeitet man an der grundrente
haben alle nicht auf das konto der spd
eingezahlt und das soziale thema das
früher ganz stark an eine soziale
schicht an die arbeiterschaft linie
gebündelt war das funktioniert so nicht
mehr also die spd verliert langsam ihre
funktion und sie schafft es nicht sich
eine andere klientel zu finden oder aber
eine eine andere thematik zu finden weil
sie ist als sehr stark auf soziale
fokussiert bei der union hatten haben
wir auch das problem dass sie versucht
einen sehr breiten konsens abzudecken
von möglichst wirtschaftsliberal bis
sozial dass die weil die charttechniker
an der börse sagen würden der die zick
zack bewegung sich doch deutlich nach
unten bewegen bei den wahlausgang
und hinzu kommt dass ich zumindest eine
gewisse personelle auszehrung beobachte
die dazu führt dass man in solchen
krisensituationen früher stets
konkurrenten da gehabt hat wo man sagt
okay wenn er es nicht kann
der übernimmt der bietet sich ohnehin an
und in beiden parteien ist das im
augenblick stark am ende
und was die digitale kompetenz betrifft
da haben wir ein problem struktureller
natur in parteien wandert man
traditionell von in jungen jahren
kleineren positionen langsam nach oben
hoch die digitalen und youtuber kultur
ist aber eine sehr junge kultur
das heißt wir haben eine überalterte
funktionärs elite in den parteien die
dafür schon technologisch kein großes
empfinden mehr hat und gerne noch jeden
tweet abzeichnen möchte das funktioniert
so nicht herr jung gab es irgendwas wo
sie sagen würden dass wenn aktion da
können sie sich vorstellen dass damit
die spd vielleicht auch wieder attraktiv
wurde weil jetzt soll ich mit die
umweltministerin wir jetzt schnell das
klimaschutzgesetz auf den weg bringen
also man man reagiert ja jetzt oder man
das hat es ja schon länger vor
aber versucht jetzt auch das tempo zu
machen also gibt's da sei was wo sie
sagen ja dass da machen dies auch ganz
gut
ok aber was heißt das denn heißt es dann
dass seine parteigänger schulze ist sehr
bemüht und weil sie ist die schwester
ministerin im ganzen kabinett und
vielleicht machen sie richtig bemessen
ist immer an den budgets der ministerien
und ich glaube das ist ja mal 2
milliarden im jahr
wir geben allein an umweltschädlichen
klima schädlichen subventionen pro jahr
57 milliarden aus klima kabinett da sind
ja die anderen ministerien
das war ja sechs wochen trifft jetzt
morgen soll sich ja zum ersten mal
treffen und was wird die das wichtigste
thema wird wieder nicht besprochen
werden die co2 steuer
also ich hab da leider überhaupt keine
hoffnung ich sehe auch das nicht dass
die spd eine soziale partei ist sie
versucht ist zu sein sie versucht sie zu
verkaufen
aber seit der agenda 2010 egal wie man
zu der agenda selbst steht hat die spd
die mit ausgelacht von leuten wenn sie
mit sozialen sozialkompetenz kommen weil
als allererstes kommt bei den bürgern
bürgerinnen agenda 2010 an
also das ist immer noch ein punkt wo sie
sagen daran krankt ihrer daran leider
ich glaube ehrlich sagen spd müsse sich
komplett neu aufstellen sie müssen aus
der groko raus sie müssen den ganzen
parteivorstand rausschmeißen und neu
wählen lassen
die partei vorstellen vorstellen sie
noch weitermachen wollen würden können
sich dann kann ja noch antreten aber es
müsste ein neues eine neue partei
entstehen
ich meine es gibt ja in portugal und in
uk gibt es gute beispiele wie es einen
linksruck durch einen erneuerungsprozess
geben kann und nicht einfach nur durch
köpfe austauschen was wäre sollen nach
nahles kommen frau schwesig herr scholz
dann würde alles noch gesehen
er ist in der österreich hat man ja auch
lange erfahrungen mit der großen
koalition also jahrelang sp und vp hat
das beiden parteien geschadet
jahrzehntelang muss man sagen ja
inzwischen hat es ihnen geschadet
und dieses durch marschieren durch die
institutionen stimmt auch nicht mehr in
diesen beiden verteilen ich darf
erinnern wir haben eine vorsitzende bei
der spd ist vor zwei jahren beigetreten
glaube ich und der ehemalige da muss man
sagen die jüngste altkanzler aller
zeiten soll
er hat auch recht recht rapide
eigentlich diese partei haben sich
gerissen
im grunde aber selbstverständlich dass
sie machten wie macht man das
hierzulande das würde viele junge leute
gerne her also die union versucht in
bremen mit einem menschen der auch
gerade erst ein jahr in der partei ist
also insofern bestätigt das schon
ich muss jetzt auch noch betonen ich
sitze hier als vertreterin eines landes
wo man sieht dass die alternative noch
noch scheint zwar nicht das erste mal
sondern inzwischen das dritte mal im
grunde mit einer anderen koalition
das war die parteienlandschaft schaut
anders aus aber ich kann nur jetzt aus
umgekehrten vorzeichen bestätigen dass
die rolle des juniorpartners ist immer
eine unglückliche bei uns war das die
svp also die christdemokraten die
jahrzehnte lang nicht gewusst haben wie
können sie sich daraus befreien außer
eben zweimal mit den rechtspopulisten zu
koalieren und beides mal hat diese
partei sich selbst auch um diese chance
gebracht und damit glaube ich um die
ganze republik und ist auch der grund
warum ich sage österreich steckt nicht
nur in einer regierungskrise sondern in
einer staatskrise weil ich nicht weil es
im september nach der wahl welches neue
versuch welches neue versprechen kann
uns eine partei geht man dass wir
glauben mal kurz hat nur gewonnen weil
er gesagt hat er beendet diese große
koalition
herr oder wenn wir das sehen wir werden
nach österreich schauen als als etwas
als eine entwicklung die vielleicht bei
uns auch sein kann wenn wir sehen wie
schwer wie schwer sich die großen
parteien hier tun wir schauen nach
europa also wo muss man da ansetzen
eigentlich was wäre jetzt ein punkt wäre
es dann wirklich sinnvoll zu sagen ja
diese große koalition hat keinen sinn
und die parteien müssen sich auf ihre
jede partei auf ihren markenkern
konzentrieren wieder unterscheidbar
werden was würden sie eine
parteivorsitzende nahles und der
parteivorsitzende gran canaria vom
grundsatz her würde ich sagen was die
demokratie betrifft ja natürlich was wir
dringend brauchen sind unterscheidbare
inhaltlich und programmatisch
unterscheidbare große volksparteien die
zugleich artikulation fähige kraftvolle
kräfte in der politischen mitte sind wir
erleben hier diese nicht mehr
kein problem anstand unterscheidbarkeit
von pathé unterscheidbarkeit von
konzepten führt zum wettbewerb von
politischen konzepten und so liberal bin
ich dass ich wettbewerb immer noch für
das prinzip halte dass die besseren
lösungen befördert wie ihr leben eine
zunehmende polarisierung und
moralisierung unserer politischen
öffentlichkeit von seiten einer
intoleranten multikulturalisten linken
und einer nationalistischen politischen
rechten
und dazwischen sind die politischen ist
die politische mitte sind die großen
parteien weitgehend artikulation unfähig
geworden was wir brauchen sind lebendige
programmatisch inhaltlich unterscheiden
wahre volkspartei die in einen
wettbewerb der ideen treten
allerdings muss ich ihnen auch eines das
zu sagen ob das tatsächlich angesichts
des trends denen wir überall erleben
dazu führt dass die demokratie wirklich
wiederbelebt wird und die volksparteien
dann auch wieder an stärke zunehmen
das ist eine andere frage denn der
umstand dass die spd tatsächlich so viel
durchgesetzt hat wie sie in den letzten
jahren durchgesetzt hat und ihr das
überhaupt nichts genützt hat ist ja
unter dem normalen maßstäben von
demokratie dass derjenige etwas macht
dann kann auch profitieren sollte da das
wird darüber dafür stehen dass man sagt
dann schluss mit der groko so wie ich
sie jetzt verstehe ich bin schon 2017
nicht dafür gewesen da 18 ich dafür
gewesen die groko wieder aufzuleben
natürlich ist die gruppe nicht hilfreich
da sind wir bei einer selbstliebe die
spd vor sich hin her trägt das sie hat
gute gesetze macht aber die einfach die
pr scheiße ist bzw
dass sie schlecht verkauft werden wenn
sie gute gesetze wären bräuchte es keine
gute pr dann werden denn während gute
gesetze
1 1 steht es da durchaus gerechtfertigt
ausreden stattdessen nennen sie ihre
gesetze sogar gute kita gesetze damit
oma erna wahrscheinlich am ende nicht
auf die idee kommt ist das überhaupt ein
gutes gesetz nein sie nennen es gleich
so wird das problem geht wir reden hier
über pr strategie und wie sich die
parteien stellen herr jung ich rede gar
nicht nur pr die neue berichtswoche die
wetten dass ich durch die regierung
ersetzen und dann sind die regierungen
müssen handeln sie müssen taten folgen
lassen und riesa hat er völlig recht wir
müssen insbesondere klimaschutz sofort
was machen und wenn das nicht passiert
dann werden sie noch weiter ab steht
aber sie müssen ja auch
erkennen dass politische prozesse
einfach auch ein bisschen dauern dass
das nicht sein wir haben jetzt schon 20
jahre
frau merkel ist vor 20 25 jahren
umweltministerium gewesen sie hat in den
90ern in einer enquetekommission das
schon vorgelegt bekommen all das was
sowieso noch mal erklärt hat ok ich weiß
dass ich wohl gleich mehrere junge auch
dankbar wenn wir die dinge etwas
auseinander halten können dieser
populistische verabsolutierung bringt
doch die politische debatte nicht weiter
ich möchte schon noch mal sein mir geht
es nicht um die pferde spd mir geht es
um das was herr schuler sagte die spd
hat ja tatsächlich in den letzten jahren
in den großen positionen
überdurchschnittlich viel durchgesetzt
und dass die spd von ihrer programmatik
viel durchsetzt ihr das aber im
wählerzuspruch nichts nützt ist
natürlich für eine demokratische partei
ein ziemlich frustrierend es erlebt sie
hatten zum teil fragen beantwortet die
niemand gestellt hat also die rund 60
jahre wurde verkauft als etwas wurde der
dachdecker mit den morgen endlich zu
hause werden soll wofür sie genutzt wird
ist dass der gut verdienende angestellte
der sich leisten kann auch ein paar
prozentpunkte bei der rente zu
verzichten jetzt in rente geht also dem
arbeitsamt arbeitsmarkt wert von leute
entzogen und es funktioniert gar nicht
so wie es eigentlich gedacht gewesen ist
und wir erleben jetzt mit der grundrente
ohne bedürftigkeitsprüfung genau das
gleiche wieder selbst der
sozialdemokratische wähler sagt ich will
doch der arzt gattin jetzt hier nicht
die renten aufstocken bezahlen also die
ganzen sachen funktionieren so nicht und
der bürger und wähler merkt dass er
irgendwie ein hohles gebildet ob vor
sich hat was ständig kreist und sich
ständig gegenseitig behagt aber
eigentlich nicht liefert worum es geht
in zukunft gibt es denn dafür nach sagen
sie jetzt funktioniert es noch oder wird
das jetzt also wenn man jetzt wirklich
sehr dass nach zwei tage nach der wahl
sich schon ja ich also ich möchte es
nicht an einzelnen personen festmachen
manche schieben das auf den politikstil
von angela merkel die versucht das so
lange reifen zu lassen dass es irgendwie
entscheidungsreif ist aber es ist schon
ein problem wenn man versucht durch die
er durch eine gezielte anscheinend
erweckung konsens herzustellen wo man
sagt okay
die einen wollen die frauenquote wir
wollen die frauenquote nicht dann machen
wir eine frauenquote in aufsichtsräten
für dax notierte mitbestimmungspflichtig
dann kriegen die eigenen ihre quote dies
aber so ausgehöhlt das ist 100 leute in
ganz deutschland betrifft und eigentlich
auch wieder keine quote ist und so sind
alle zufrieden
dieser politikstil kann eigentlich auf
der straße niemanden zufriedenstellen
ich möchte kurz mak aus dem feuer nehmen
und an angela merkel erinnern weil sie
ist die hauptperson die hauptangeklagte
in wieses video die wird also seit tagen
überhaupt nicht gefragt was sie dazu
sagt dass sie sich dazu äußert ich höre
davon ihren nichts dabei wird versucht
da gefragt schon aber sie sagt sie will
nicht sagen dass ist das ist versagen
und außerdem in allerdings immer noch
die beliebteste politiker das verstehe
ich halt auch nicht aber komplett
ignoriert
aber gerade als beliebteste politikerin
unverantwortliche der letzten 14 jahre
kann man doch auf diese anklage
antworten und außerdem wurde ja bei mir
ist nicht nur die cdu angegriffen
sondern auch die spd die csu das haben
wir jetzt werden wir müssen aber bei der
ultima realität die das klimateam thema
gerade bekommt müssen wir auch sagen
wenn wir eine art notstandsgesetze
fordern dass es geht um das überleben
des planeten deshalb sind keine debatte
nötig dass das funktioniert in einem
demokratisch freiheitlich verfassten
land nicht weil es muss möglich sein zu
debattieren
und wir müssen uns einfach auch mal klar
machen dass der wohlstand dieses landes
auf der flexibilität auf der mobilität
von waren und personen beruht in einem
maße wie wir uns das oft nicht klar
machen wir können also versuchen
prohibitiv so zu besteuern dass wir den
leuten die das autofahren unmöglich
machen und den warenverkehr zum beispiel
just in time nicht mehr möglich machen
dass das kann man lernen kann man machen
man muss dann aber auch sehen dass man
möglicherweise entweder gelb westen
prozess der erntet oder andere
wirtschaftseinbrüche die natürlich von
energie leben es hätte sich auch wieder
an die ak die auch immer sagt wir können
kein klimaschutz machen wenn solange der
wohlstand gefährdet wird diese weise
kein klimaschutz ohne wohlstands
bewahrung und das ist völliger humbug
aber manchmal ist unser aktuelles
wirtschaftssystem hat dazu geführt dass
unser planet so abgehackt darum müssen
wir unser handelswege und so weiter
alles überdenken also das ist ja kaum
trennen ich glaube dass bei den
erneuerbaren so weit wie wir kaum ein
land zahlt so hohen preis als umlage für
erneuerbare kohlekraftwerke diese soll
bis 2030 weil wir völlig sinnloser weise
aus der atomkraft ausgestiegen sind was
eine co2 freie technik ist das würde
ganz gerne letzten zwei minuten nochmal
nutzung ganz kurz nach brüssel zu
schauen und zu fragen
wenn wir jetzt weil sie haben ja sagen
ja auch deutschland muss eigentlich
stärker werden in europa muss dann eine
stärkere rolle einfühlen können sie sich
vorstellen dass angela merkel dann doch
sagt okay sie geht nach brüssel
ausgeschlossen hat wäre das sinnvoll um
dann sozusagen die interessen in
deutschland durchzusetzen
nein wir erleben doch dass sie ihre
angela merkels zu ende geht und man muss
das irgendwann politisch auch mal
realisieren
und wir erleben stattdessen im moment
eine situation des politischen
stillstands der europa nicht gut tut
bis heute hat deutschland auf die
vorschläge von emanuel makro nicht
wirklich reagiert und europa leidet
unter einem mangel an deutsche
orientierung und ein deutscher führung
europa ist konfrontiert ist bedrängt von
innen durch populistische bewegungen von
allen seiten durch von außen bedrängt
durch einen amerikanischen präsidenten
durch die türkei durch russland aus dem
nahen osten das heißt während der gewinn
vor allem setzen deutschen
kommissionspräsidenten gibt das ist
nicht die frage des
kommissionspräsidenten die deutsche die
deutsche regierung muss handeln wir
brauchen eine stärkere engagiertere
deutsche regierung in europa die ihrer
verantwortung für europa gerecht wird
was politische führung an und im übrigen
sich auch in projekten beispielsweise in
der klima oder im umweltschutz politik
engagieren kann
aber wir brauchen eine engagiertere
deutsche politik in europa deutschland
versagt in europa sieht man das in
österreich auch so also nicht stört
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen das mailing
wenn sie seien
er ist deutschlands zu retten ich glaube
wir brauchen eine starke kommission
deutschland gesagt was heißt die
vertritt die interessen europas uns die
österreicher sind ja im moment aus dem
spiel
es geht um die interessen europa so
nicht um die interessen deutschlands
oder irgendeines anderen landes okay der
schule wir schaffen das nicht mehr wir
müssen jetzt wünschen am ende dieser
diskussion leider und ich muss mal kurz
also ganz vielen dank für die diskussion
bis hierher wäre reden natürlich in den
nächsten tagen noch weiter darüber aber
sie kennen das nach der findungsrunde
phoenix der tag in bonn und dort ist
mein kollege thomas bade thomas ihr
guckt nach brüssel oder was macht ja
also erstmal habe ich gespannt die runde
verfolgt aber währenddessen habe
natürlich auch nach brüssel geschaut
eine schlagzeile kann ja schon verraten
es gibt noch keinen neuen
missions- präsidenten und das sind im
einzelnen unsere themen wir berichten
ausführlich über den eu-sondergipfel und
der mühsamen suche nach einem
kommissionspräsidenten
wir berichten auch über die entscheidung
von andrea nahles schon nächste woche
die wahlen zum fraktionsvorsitz abhalten
zu wollen und wir berichten natürlich
auch über den stress den acker gerade
mit der meinungsfreiheit hat also ich
würde sagen bei den innenpolitischen
themen schließen wir das an was seine
runde diskutiert haben und bei brüssel
hoffen wir dass er vielleicht sogar in
der stunde noch ein paar neue sachen
rauskriegen gut vielen dank thomas bade
also bleiben sie dran phoenix der tag
und morgen gibt es ja durch wieder in
der phoenix runde versetzen die
situation die wir eigentlich hier auch
noch eine stunde weiterführen könnten
setzen wir einfach fort denn morgen
heißt es streit um meinungsfreiheit
youtuber gegen groko und dann erwarten
wir ruprecht polenz von der cdu robbin
blase besser bekannt als ob babbel und
karin [ __ ] von der spd also schauen
sowie dazu misst dann herzlichen dank
für die diskussion
[Musik]